my name is Carmelina right the day I was
born was the day the world collapsed
those that survived how to make new
lives underground up above there was
nothing but ash and cold and death
people thought it would last forever but
without us up there life returned
spoiler alert at the end of Far Cry 5
the United States gets nuked
17 years later the region and residents
of Hope County have endured and mostly
recovered from the devastation anew the
vegetation is more abundant Society has
been reshaped and there is a hell of a
lot more duct tape everywhere everything
feels new and different well except for
the fact that there's a ruthless
tyrannical oppression taking over
everything it's up to you and basically
only you to stop it some things never
change
that's far cry new dawn despite a few
new novelties and a great mechanical
twist new dawn feels exactly like what
it is a direct continuation of far cry 5
and you know that's not inherently a bad
thing new dawn peach is the same kind of
forward-thinking approach to open-world
exploration and progression as far cry 5
while main missions are mapped out for
you the discovery of side activities
like enemy outposts treasure hunts and
companion recruitment missions and
mostly comes from your own organic
exploration earning perk points to
improve your abilities is tied to your
discovery of hidden caches and
diversifying the activities you want to
take new dawn is a more concise game the
map is smaller than Far Cry 5 and
there's less curated content to discover
this time around but the emphasis is
still on staying out in the world and
soaking up the environment
the sense of freedom has been diminished
however it's not the fact that you're
revisiting Hope County but rather how
new dawn sets up the pins in Far Cry 5
you began in the middle of the map and
you had the freedom to explore in any
direction you wished new dawn starts you
off in the bottom corner of a map and
basically pushes you in a steady linear
sweep north as you slowly reclaim
territory and asks you to regularly
bring resources back to your base in
that starting area to bolster it so
what's to stop you from just darting
ahead
well damage numbers new dawn introduces
RPG elements like damage numbers into
its design for the first time in this
series the game's guns and enemies fall
into four different tiered ranks and
getting your head requires you to go out
in the world to scavenge crafting
materials to upgrade your base so you
can upgrade your weapons workshop and
eventually craft better guns to take
down higher rank enemies impeding your
progress outfits armor and defense
numbers don't factor into your growth
just weapons guns at rank one and two
will do a minimal amount of damage to
well armoured rank three in elite
ranking meets early on this can be
annoying if you try to push the limits
of the game in a way you're not meant to
heading too far into the map and needing
to use up hundreds of bullets to take
down our rank three bear you encounter
isn't as terrifying as much as it is
silly and eventually the demands of the
story missions will stop you from going
too far
but if you dial down your Far Cry 5
style expectations of freedom and go
with the flow you'd run into these
awkward predicaments far less often your
guns feel like they do the damage
they're supposed to and enemies feel
like they have an acceptable level of
resistance in fact once you get access
to the top tier arsenal things will
start to swing wildly in your favor your
guns will feel overpowered to the point
where even shooting Rank 1 enemies in
the foot might be enough to take them
out which feels great when you're
getting overwhelmed if you play it the
right way the game's IBG style systems
basically feel invisible and you can
enjoy Far Cry style of weighty gunplay
and feel like an incredibly competent
one-person army the feeling of
eventually being able to overcome new
Dawn's elite enemies is good but you're
eventually left wondering why you needed
to be held back by artificial gaining at
all it doesn't help that there's no
tangible sense of growth with weapons
and vehicle crafting new dawn selections
of guns and
isn't dramatically different enough
between ranks to make the large
distinction and damage output believable
rank one weapons are a varied suite of
handguns rifles and shotguns and high
ranked Arsenal's are basically defined
by the increasing amount of duct tape
and junk on that same suite as if that
stuff had magical properties then made
the guns perform better there are a lot
of guns to choose from but if he's
played Far Cry 5 you'll immediately
recognize them duct tape or no the one
nice exception is the noose or launcher
which fires circular saw blades higher
two versions of the weapon actually have
noticeably different properties like the
ability to shoot saw blades with
ricocheting homing and boomerang
properties it's the only weapon which
truly feels like it was born out of the
post apocalypse improvised from
scavenged parts aerosol cans pipes and
spray-paint may give the other guns and
cars a cool look but they don't change
how familiar they feel the same can be
said of the world itself Far Cry 5s Hope
County already felt a little bit
post-apocalyptic the rural setting was
isolated from the world thanks to
antagonist Joseph C so even though there
are plenty of visible differences to the
region the impact of those changes isn't
massive there are a few key locations
that provoke some amusement in their
discovery but the strength of Far Cry
soap County was its natural environments
the forests the lakes the rivers and
mountains the conceit that the region
was revegetated by a super blue muffin
nuclear devastation means that the vibe
in New Dawn is basically identical
despite dramatic increases in upended
cars and graffiti it's a pretty post
apocalypse but it doesn't have the
feeling of desperation you might
associate with the theme scavenging for
materials doesn't feel like a drastic
necessity it's just a way to get ahead
new dawn doesn't feel like it takes the
theme to enough of an extreme to make it
feel meaningful or different the solid
bones of farc rise combat and
progression are still here though and
they're still very good taking on
outposts within your rank whether that
be by stealth or aggression is still
enjoyable and the game encourages you to
repeat them at increased difficulties to
earn more resources
new dawn also introduces self-contained
emissions called expeditions these are
large diverse maps set outside herp
County and they feature set pieces like
a New Orleans amusement park an aircraft
carrier and even a Splinter Cell themed
plane crash expedition environments are
a highlight but the snatch-and-grab
objectives mean that you're never really
encouraged to stop and appreciate them
you're more concerned with getting the
hell out of there as a non-stop stream
of enemies comes after you the concise
nature of the game means there's a
remarkable lack of time given to
appreciate the characters and plot - a
few of the major characters feel like
they could be interesting the twin
sister antagonists especially but the
few interactions you have with them are
definitely not enough to develop them
and to make you care while the
performances have gusto key moments of
pathos just feel completely unearned
undeveloped connections to characters
also exacerbate the relative mundanity
of the story missions compared to the
games side and open wall activities and
talking tired sequences bland chases
forced melee fights and even a slow boat
ride all of which just go on for way too
long
you do get a double jump though that's
right a double jump as in the ability to
jump in midair you also get the ability
to basically turn invisible and give
yourself super speed and strength
now the Far Cry series has always
dabbled in the mystic but yes in a
strange turn of events you don't
eventually says [ __ ] it and gives you
access to superhuman powers and the way
it changes how you approach the world is
undoubtedly the best thing about the
game these sudden powers let you lean
hard into superhero fantasy allowing you
to do things like bound of offenses and
onto buildings using your newfound
mobility and invisibility to completely
terrorize enemies like you're the
predator or perhaps you're jumping high
into the fray and firing off explosive
arrows pretending you're Hawkeye from
the avengers maybe you're more of a
Wolverine activating the Berserker
ability to rush an outpost at SuperSpeed
and send heavily armed assailants and
bears are like flying with just your
bare fists the powers are so good that
it's almost a shame that they come at a
point late in the game where you'll
likely already be well equipped to deal
with elite ranked enemies since a few
scenarios that challenge your ability to
use these effectively definitely would
have been a welcome addition
but as
stands that our fantastic expansion of
fire cries combat vocabulary they
completely elevate your confidence to
rip through everything and everyone
suddenly turning new Dawn's familiar
pedestrian experience into a raucous
blast there's a lot of potential and the
ideas seeded in you dawn but there isn't
enough room for many of them to breathe
so none of them feel like they realize
their full potential not the post
apocalypse themes not the RPG mechanics
not the weapons vehicles plot or
characters
regardless progressing through the
adventure is an enjoyable experience
especially once you get your superhuman
powers but this is largely because Far
Cry 5s combat and progression models
remain compelling enough to propel you
forward for its part though you don't as
a palatable but unremarkable spin-off
that feels like it could have achieved
so much more now come on go grab a drink
it's long overdue